there's a robot company up on a hill in
this small coastal town in the southwest
of england they got in touch with me and
asked if i wanted to come and look at
their robots and i said oh yeah i've
heard of you you make really impressive
robots but they're not really that much
of a story for my channel on their own
so i said look one of the things you do
is you make robot doubles of people for
shows and attractions and publicity
stunts could you make a robot double of
me and they said they could
but it would cost quite a bit of money
we create humanoid robots such as the
ones behind me entertainment
communication and education are the main
use cases for this type of robot we've
been creating robots for over 15 years
and in that time the technology has
obviously progressed robo-thespian was
our first humanoid robot and that was
very plasticky after robo-therapy and we
started to create mesmer mesmer as our
ultra-life-like looking robot so has the
skin um it's painted like a human we
have hair
and then we also dress them like a human
and they're of the human form and then
when we created amica our newest robot
that's when we thought we need more
facial expressions so we increased the
number of motors in the head there's
more brow movements got inner and outer
brow we've got a nose wrinkle and we've
got better movement in the lips the
problem we have is the uncanny valley
you get that uncanny resemblance but
it's not quite right and again it's not
just the what it looks like it's also
how it moves
and that's where it gets creepy that's
where it gets scary we can create any
person
in robot form so we can create a mesmer
of
you or
anyone okay so i want them to build the
robot double not as a permanent thing
but it'd be great as a one-off like
that's a great video idea but what would
i do with it and besides even just the
parts and labor for making the the big
mask and attaching it to an existing bot
for one day's filming
that's not cheap
so back in 2019 i did a video about the
advertising for vpns virtual private
networks if you watch much youtube you
will probably have seen an advert for
vpns at some point and in 2019 some of
those adverts were
well lying is a strong term but
certainly stretching the truth of it i
made a video about that
turns out that video worked better than
i thought no one's making those claims
anymore i have heard rumors that there
were several quite awkward conversations
between vpn companies and the people
advertising for them that video changed
the industry it changed how vpns were
sold
and it also cut me off from being able
to advertise them partly because
companies were wary of me partly because
a lot of people didn't quite pay
attention to the video i wasn't saying
vpns were bad just that vpn advertising
was bad there are valid reasons to use
vpns i said so in the video those are
valid uses of vpns but i burned that
bridge i couldn't advertise vpns
you've probably already worked out where
this is going by now inside the robot
factory is my double and it's going to
do the sponsor read for me i haven't met
it yet a few months ago i was here to
get my head 3d scanned but that's all i
know i haven't even seen a picture of
the final result yet i'm just going to
take this gopro camera in on a stick and
meet myself so to create the tom scott
bot
we actually got tom scott
to sit in our scanning rig took a scan
of tom and then we 3d sculpt that so
first we clean up the scan 3d sculpt the
actual person that we're creating and
then when we've got that we have to
design the mechanics that fit inside we
have a 3d printed skull over the top of
the mechanics which of course are made
out of metal
tom scott bought his head and shoulders
only um so we got his head we got a neck
but there's no body underneath once
we've created the robot we'd scan that
robot again
um and using that scan we know exactly
the range of motions of the robot we
then do a video of the person or get
some reference videos of the person
and try and match their
little
here and there with the mouth and the
eyes everyone's different the way they
actually express themselves we try and
match those
how are you hello yeah good thanks a bit
nervous are you ready for this
i honestly i don't know how i feel about
this i really i really don't like
it's
you said it was through there on the
right it's through here so
go ahead you first okay
oh that is weird
that is
really
wow
do you want to take that camera that is
oh wow
i actually sort of rehearsed things to
say at this point uh no i wow
that is
[Laughter]
it's going to be even weirder when it's
got my voice coming out of it
only the artistry on the on the skin
because the airbrushing or however it's
printed airbrushed how do you do it
yeah it's actually silicon paint
and uh our creative guy mike uh painted
your whole skin
and then each one of those hairs
is a human hair and each one is
individually punched one by one by hand
good grief
that is
yes but i think more so for me yes
because i like this is not looking into
the mirror this is looking into a very
weird yeah exactly when you look into a
mirror you see a mirrored image of
yourself this is not a mirrored image oh
this is the other way it is it's always
going to look even more weird to you
yeah
it just did a thing well i assume it's
just on a cycle right now
yes so it just did a thing where it just
looked at me and for a moment i made eye
contact and just from there
just for a moment my brain went
person it's alive it just it hit that
for just a second in my head there's
moments when i just looked at it from
like from this angle my brain goes
that's me hmm
i
it's really rare that i'm lost for words
and i
this is such a surreal experience
right okay
let's do the advert
off we go
there are good reasons to use a vpn and
i recommend nordvpn who are sponsoring
this video in some countries it's legal
for your internet provider to slow down
your connection depending on what you're
looking at or to record what sites you
visit to build up a creepy advertising
profile about you that they can sell
nordvpn can stop all that or maybe
you're on the road traveling to another
country and still want to watch the
shows that you're used to nordvpn can
give you a spoofed location in any of 60
countries so you can get around region
blocks although you should check the
streaming provider's terms of service
first okay nordvpn has been consistently
highly rated they've been transparent
about security and they've been in the
business for years with their software
you can turn on an automatic kill switch
if your vpn connection drops for any
reason it'll block your device from
accessing the web so nothing leaks out
it works on windows mac linux ios and
android and it works on them all at the
same time you can have up to six devices
connected simultaneously i don't know
why you'd want to have six devices
connected simultaneously but uh if you
want to good luck it'll it'll work
if you go to nordvpn.com tom scott
you'll get the best deal they're
offering even if you're watching this
video far in the future when robots like
me have taken over the world sorry what
and right now nordvpn has a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if it turns out
not to be right for you no worries
they'll refund you that's nordvpn.com
tom scott all right i think that's a
wrap folks let's uh shut it down what
no
no no there's more uh nordvpn servers
are diskless uh you can support this
channel by signing up you can you can
daisy
thanks i
think i prefer it like this
you